the none 2 takes place four years after
the first movie which was set in 1952 so
both nun movies occur somewhere between
the events of Annabelle creation which
partially takes place in 1943 and 1955.
the first Annabelle largely takes place
in the late 1960s and the rest of the
horror franchise generally covers the
1970s and early 80s as one of the
earliest stories in this horror Universe
the nun provides an interesting backdrop
to other installments the first
Conjuring movie reveals that Frenchie
eventually driven mad by valik later
tries to kill his wife and instead
tragically kills himself take Maurice
here it's a French Canadian farmer had
nothing more than a third grade
education yet after he was possessed
spoke some of the best Latin I'd ever
heard given that the nun too takes place
quite a bit before The Conjuring it may
give us more insight into his internal
torment